pour les jeunes comme moi la retraite
serait plutôt sauver la planète mais
dites pas que j'ai rien fait ou ne fait
que des hashtag
[Musique]
comment pouvez-vous prévoir si lanterne
alors que votre réforme ne prend pas en
compte l'écologie ni quoi que ce soit
depuis le début de votre quinquennat
vous communiquer sur ça avec des haches
tags etc mais rien n'est fait comment
allez vous adresser ces problèmes un
choc pour les jeunes comme moi à la
retraite serait plutôt sauver la planète
et pas cotisé accès la merci merci
monsieur thomas il m'a pas tellement
posé une question sur les retraites mais
au fond sur l'écologie à juste titre il
est tout d'abord vous avez raison alors
bon vous êtes m'avait fait un énorme
tacle par derrière
disons que je faisais que des hashtags
que j'en avais rien à faire moi j'veux
plus je plaide que c'est pas juste mais
il faut le plaider en actes non mais
faut le plaider en actes savez votre
génération qui arrive à la citoyenneté
ma génération qui est en responsabilité
politique c'est la première qui a des
choses à faire concrètes
on a rendu hommage à jacques chirac qui
était un grand président qui est le
premier à exprimer la conscience
écologique quand il a dit notre maison
brûle dans la tête et nous regardons
ailleurs
c'était il ya bientôt 20 ans donc
aujourd'hui c'est plus le temps de
l'indignation de la conscience ça
c'était le temps de jacques chirac et de
ceux qui avaient un peu de retard sur
lui
ensuite il ya eu le temps plus facile de
ce qu'ils avaient à prendre des lois
pour le futur les cinq huit dernières
années on faisait des supers loire n'en
disait dans 2040-2050 vous verrez alors
là parce que vous allez voir
bon nous on n'a pas de chance vous et
moi avons tant que citoyen en tant que
président nous de prendre les décisions
maintenant je peux pas vous laisser dire
qu'on a rien fait c'est un vrai nom si
on prend le réchauffement climatique
j'ai quand même défendre ma cause
mon but mais mon bout de gras si on
prend le réchauffement climatique la
france elle a une situation je parle
devant votre mère qui est un ancien
d'edf
on a une chance nous hein c'est notre
parc nucléaire parce que le nucléaire
c'est quand même avec leurs oeufs avec
le renouvelable ce qui permet de
produire de l'énergie non intermittente
la plus propre
c'est clair et je regarde nos voisins
qui ont parfois fermé le nucléaire comme
les allemands ils ont rouvert du charbon
et ils polluent beaucoup plus
donc nous on a cette trajectoire qu'est
ce qu'on a fait qu'est ce qu'on a décidé
de faire derrière pour la première fois
on s'est engagé dans le quinquennat moi
j'ai pas parlé pour derrière on a dit on
ferme
toutes les usines à charbon qui nous
reste il y en a cinq
mais je peux vous dire je peux vous
invitez s'ils voulaient venir avec moi
aller discuter avec les salariés
quand vous avez à saint-avold quand vous
avez au havre ou ailleurs des milliers
de salariés à qui on vous dit on croit
dans la transition écologique on veut
réduire les émissions les mecs pas de
chance on ferme les usines c'est ça fait
des travaux pratiques maintenant on est
aux travaux pratiques
donc on y passe faut le faire mais je
vous laisserai pas dire qu'on ne l'ait
qu'on ne fait rien c'est faux mais c'est
difficile il faut plutôt aider le
gouvernement à le faire elle expliqué et
derrière ce qu'on fait à chaque fois
c'est de construire des projets qui sont
cohérents et donc des projets qui sont
dans la biomasse des projets qui sont
dans les énergies renouvelables ou de
reconversion mais ça se fait pas en un
claquement de doigts c'est pas vrai
deuxio on a interdit toutes les
nouvelles explorations et exploitations
d'hydrocarbures sur notre territoire
moi j'avais personnes avec moi qui est
venu expliquer aux guyanais a les
copains tous vos voisins ils ont déplu
de pétrole ils sont en train d exploiter
on leur dit c'est le nouveau mexique
mais vous fini je les assume à fond
parce que j'y crois me dit pas je n'y
crois pas mais ça faut aller le dire aux
gens et donc on a un problème aussi
c'est que on est dans le toujours plus
mais personne ne regarde la transition
ça c'est sur les émissions de co2 on
parle de biodiversité moi je veux qu'on
sorte des pièces des pesticides mais pas
que j'ai rien fait ou ne fait que des
hashtag si la france n'avait pas été là
on était reparti pour 15 ans sur le
glyphosate parce qu'on s'est battus cinq
ans mais c'est même de le faire en trois
ans mais je vais pas l'expliquer aux
fils de madame que je vais demander lui
à le faire en un an et demi ou sortir
tout de suite du glyphosate alors que à
500 km il ya un concurrent espagnol ou
allemand dans son secteur d'ailleurs ce
serait plutôt néerlandais qui lui a le
droit d'y aller à gogo je le tue donc
j'ai besoin de faire bouger les autres
européens au moins aussi vite que moi
c'est ça la vie donc ce que je dis
souvent l'indignation de la jeunesse sur
ce
j'ai j'en ai besoin pour nous faire
bouger tous coty vivement mais nous
sommes au temps des travaux pratiques
j'ai besoin d'une indignation qui
contribuent et qui aide qui est d'aller
nettoyer les rivières qui sont polluées
qui aident à former dans les écoles pour
aller sensibiliser tout le monde sur le
tri sélectif qui aident à les
sensibiliser et poussé pour que sur tous
ces sujets on change et qui m'aident à
expliquer aux gens à qui on demande des
changements très dur sinon on devient
dans un monde de fous où il ya d'un côté
des gens qui disent vous n'allez jamais
assez vite vous en faites pas sur
l'écologie vous fait que des acheteurs
et de l'autre côté des gens qui disent
vous êtes en train de nous tuer avec
votre d'écologie parce que moi je suis
paysan j'arrive déjà pas à vivre moi je
suis dans une entreprise et vous fermez
tout donc il faut que notre nation
sèches se rassembler pour dire on sera
intraitable parce que pour votre
génération
on doit sortir de la dépendance réduire
le co2 être à nos objectifs est allé de
plus en plus vite
il faut changer les comportements et
donc moi mon message c'est vous avez
complètement raison
c'est au moins aussi importante est
traité pour moi c'est très important il
ya une convention citoyenne qui pour la
première fois sa salle vendredi
aucun pays n'a fait comme nous on a tiré
au sort 150 citoyens pour qu'ils nous
aident à trouver des solutions concrètes
et les plus vite mais ça doit être un
agenda de solutions maintenant ça peut
plus être en agenda d'incantation ou
d'indignation
d'abord parce que c'est trop facile de
s'indigner c'est trop facile
moi j'ai besoin de l'énergie que tout le
monde si vous indigner venait m'aider